soll man nie gedenken im iran
hunderttausende menschen begleiten die
trauerzüge für den getöteten general
tödliches unglück in südtirol ein
betrunkener autofahrer fährt in eine
menschenmenge sechs junge deutsche
sterben vor dem letzten springen in
bischofshofen karl geiger wird
sechzehnter in der qualifikation hat
aber immer noch chancen auf den tournee
gesamtsieg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen am sonntag zu einem kurzen
nachrichten überblick und auch für den
sport ist gesorgt mit norbert lehmann
ein stück von mir
wohin führt der konflikt zwischen den
usa und dem iran die gezielte tötung von
general sulimani zieht nun
wechselseitige drohungen nach sich rache
schwere der iraner beantwortet
us-präsident trump auf twitter heute mit
der ankündigung im fall iranischer
attacken 52 ziele dort sehr schnell und
sehr hart anzugreifen
im iran formierten sich unterdessen
große trauer züge in mehreren städten
basel berichtet generell solle man die
sterbliche überreste sind zurück in der
heimat
hunderttausende drängen sich in der
heiligen stadt maschad um den sagt auf
seiner dreitägigen reise durchs land es
sind demonstrationen so groß wie vor 30
jahren bei der beerdigung ajatollah
chomeinis im gründer der islamischen
republik
und es ist eine gigantische inszenierung
der staatsführung die botschaft das
iranische volk ist verletzt es ist
wütend und es ist entschlossen sohle
mannis tod zu rächen und sich dem feind
entgegenzustellen
tod den usa skandieren irans abgeordnete
im parlament ist die feindschaft zu den
vereinigten staaten und israel antrieb
iranischer politik seit der islamischen
revolution vor 40 jahren
so erlebt der hass nach dem tod seiner
mannis einen neuen höhepunkt
ich rate den amerikanern besser ihre
sachen zu packen und aus der region zu
verschwinden bevor etwas passiert per
twitter warnte us-präsident trump sollte
iran als vergeltung amerikanische ziele
angreifen werde er schnell und hart
zurückschlagen
nach dem tod des ehemannes wächst die
kriegsgefahr in der region
jetzt wird viel telefoniert und
verhandelte zu verhindern dass der
konflikt außer kontrolle gerät doch der
einfluss der europäer ist dabei nur
gering und schlimmer noch die iranische
führung könnte jetzt bald weitere
verstöße gegen das atom abkommen
verkünden und damit die lage noch weiter
verschärfen
trauer und zorn am vormittag bereits im
südwest iranischen ach was in der nacht
soll der leichnam solle moniz in der
hauptstadt teheran eintreffen
morgen findet dort die zentrale
trauerfeier statt
auch im nachbarland irak hat der angriff
der usa weitere konsequenzen
das parlament fordert dass alle
internationalen truppen aus dem land
abziehen
eine entsprechende resolution
verabschiedeten die abgeordneten am
nachmittag in bagdad der einsatz der
amerikanisch geführten militärkoalition
gegen den es müsse beendet werden
frage an unseren usa korrespondenten
elmar theveßen
wie wird denn nun diese folge des
angriffs auf soll imani in washington
bewertet ja diese forderung aus bagdad
die stößt natürlich hier auf ablehnung
außenminister profil hat heute im
fernsehen gesagt das sei sicherlich
nicht im interesse des irakischen volkes
tatsächlich wäre ein amerikanischer
abzug ja auch ein politisches desaster
für die us-regierung denn man würde den
irak ja letztlich dem iranischen
einfluss überlassen
dass es nicht im sinne der us-regierung
zu allem überfluss hat präsident trump
eben getwittert diese 52 ziele angreifen
zu wollen wenn der iran tatsächlich
rache üben sollte für die tötung von
sony und er hat dabei auch chile
eingeschlossen ausdrücklich die
kulturell für den iran wichtig sind das
wäre nach internationalem recht und auch
nach amerikanischen gesetzen eigentlich
dann ein kriegsverbrechen mit dem donald
trump hier droht und man merkt daran das
ganze offenbar
diese tötung von sulimani auch politisch
massiven schaden hier in den usa
anrichtet und auch in anderen teilen der
welt
die einschätzung von elmar theveßen
vielen dank dafür nach washington ins
inland csu-chef söder will eine baldige
regierungsumbildung wissen mitte des
jahres sollte das kabinett verjüngt und
erneuert werden sagte er der bild am
sonntag welche minister gehen sollten
sagte söder nicht es gehe um inhalte
daran müsse für die union das thema das
thema innovation und wirtschaft an
erster stelle stehen ein schrecklicher
unfall vergangene nacht in südtirol ein
autofahrer ist in eine gruppe junger
menschen gefahren sechs von ihnen
starben mehrere wurden schwer verletzt
alle todesopfer kommen aus deutschland
das unglück ereignete sich nördlich von
bozen in der wintersportregion ahrntal
im ort luther der fahrer überlebte den
unfall er war stark betrunken
annette hilsenbeck berichtet sie stellen
kerzen auf hinterlassen botschaften dort
wo die deutschen urlauber ihr leben
verloren
die bewohner des örtchens luthers sind
erschüttert von iak leider trüben
und sowas dürfte normal nicht passieren
darf nicht besiegt an dieser hauptstraße
waren die reisenden aus deutschland nach
einem discobesuch nachts aus dem bus
gestiegen wollten ins hotel wie die
polizei rekonstruiert um kurz nach eins
raste ein auto in die 17-köpfige gruppe
die menschen wurden mit arbeit durch die
luft geschleudert der 27 jährige fahrer
hatte zum zeitpunkt des unfalls mehr als
1,9 promille alkohol im blut
neben den toten gibt es elf verletzt
vier davon schwer sie wurden demnach den
umliegende krankenhäuser gebracht
der menge der verletzten wurden
natürlich ein massives aufgebot an
nachalarmiert es fehlen einem die worte
auf grund von diesem geschehen und
dementsprechend ist auch ist auch hier
die situation in den dörfern noch einer
bevölkerung die natürlich mit dem mit
einem christen hier mit viel auch am
abend trauert man die staatsanwaltschaft
hat derweil die ermittlungen aufgenommen
der fahrer muss sich wegen tötung im
straßenverkehr verantworten
spaniens geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident hat die erste
abstimmung für seine wiederwahl im
parlament verloren in madrid verfehlte
der sozialist pedro sanchez die absolute
mehrheit
bei einer zweiten abstimmung am dienstag
genügt dann die einfache mehrheit
diese dürfte sánchez erreichen da sich
18 abgeordnete einer katalanischen
separatistenpartei enthalten wollen das
drei sterne restaurant schwarzwaldstube
im baden-württembergischen baiersbronn
gilt als top ziel für gomez jetzt ist es
komplett ausgebrannt das feuer in dem
hotel traube tonbach brach in der nacht
aus die ursache ist unklar verletzt
wurde niemand
die feuerwehr geht von einem
millionenschaden aus
und nun zu dir norbert und zur
vierschanzentournee
letzte station heute bischofshofen ja
heute die qualifikation unterrichteten
sich aus deutscher sicht alle augen auf
den größten hoffnungsträger karl geiger
nachdem er zuvor schon in innsbruck
gepatzt hatte heute nur ein sechzehnter
platz seine direkten konkurrenten und
dem gesamtsieg spangen allesamt besser
die hoffnung auf einen turniersieg von
karl geiger sie ist nicht größer
geworden viel luft nach oben beim
deutschen nur 128 meter heute er muss
zulegen würde um den gesamt sieg
mitspringen
den besten eindruck unter den gesamtsieg
favoriten hinterlässt der japaner
kobayashi sechster mit 134 metern siege
heute der österreicher kraft im
gegensatz zu geiger aber ohne
realistische chance auf den gesamtsieg
dabei auf angriff gehen
das gehe jeden wettkampf und ich werde
mich auf jeden fall top vorbereiten und
alles geben
karl geiger will kämpfen grübelt und
hofft seine trainer haben mit der
analyse schon am schanzentisch begonnen
morgen gilt es die kleine chance auf den
gesamtsieg beim schopf zu packen
weltmeisterin tina herrmann hat sich im
skeleton weltcup eindrucksvoll
zurückgemeldet beim rennen in winterberg
große freude bei der 27-jährigen denn es
war ihr erster sieg im dritten
saisonrennen mit nur drei hundertstel
sekunden vorsprung verwies sie die
kanadierin mirella wieder auf rang zwei
die winterbergerin jacqueline nelling
die die weltcup-gesamtwertung weiter
anführt wurde auf ihrer heimbahn vierte
die deutschen tennis männer dürfen bei
dtp cup in australien weiter auf den
einzug in die ko runde hoffen
dank kevin krawietz und andreas mies sie
gewannen gegen das griechische doppel
stefanos tsialis und michael backes
knapp in drei sätzen zuvor hatte
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
alexander zverev erneut sein einzel
verloren
sein teamkollege die 100 chf dagegen
siegte und am dienstag geht es dann
gegen kanada um den einzug in die
ko-runde
danke norbert und gerade nochmal aktuell
zum thema iran das land hat soeben
bekannt gegeben sich überhaupt nicht
mehr an das atom abkommen von 2015
halten zu wollen
bleibt noch das wetter im westen und
süden zeigt sich nach frühnebel die
sonne sonst bleibt es oft trüb oder die
sonne lässt sich erst am nachmittag
sehen
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 0
und 8 grad so viel für den moment mehr
gibt es um 21 45 und heute journal mit
claus kleber und morgen freut sich
barbara hahlweg an dieser stelle auf sie
wir wünschen noch einen schönen
sonntagabend und empfehlen in jetzt
berlin direkt mit einem interview von
theo koll mit alt bundespräsident gauck